[Musique]
alors alors mes chers amis la campagne
qui s'ouvre est évidemment très
particulière c'est une campagne éclair
mais les enjeux sont immenses
c'est au fond la mère des batailles dans
cette année de respiration démocratique
qui ne répond à aucune autre c'est elle
qui va fixer les grandes orientations du
pays pour les cinq années à venir
et c'est vous qui choisiraient le cap à
suivre
je voudrais que nous saisissions à bras
le corps avec optimisme et esprit de
conquête la chance que constitue les
bouleversements que nous observons et
que nous avons vécu ces derniers jours
je voudrais que nous reprenions le
flambeau du progrès de l'avenir que nous
sommes les seuls à pouvoir brandir d'une
main audacieuse et sans ambiguïté je
voudrais que nous donnions la france une
majorité de droite et du centre je
voudrais que nous donnions au pays un
gouvernement de droite et du centre au
fond je voudrais qu emmanuel macron et
la majorité qu'il faut à la france une
majorité sans ambiguïté sans faux
semblants une vraie majorité et non une
majorité de circonstance de rencontre et
d'ambitions personnelles